hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing yes
there is new DLC for this game and yes
we are going to get right back into it
and yes we are picking up the adventure
of mum Fleur fum / tink the snake oiler
who was formerly a cowpuncher who was
now going back into this game
now it has been a very very very long
time since I played this game not
terribly wrong not terribly long but
it's been a while and I'm super excited
for it because I always said that I was
gonna come back to this game but then I
didn't have a reason to come back to
this game because the after the end of
the game there really wasn't all that
much to do but now there is so to get to
the DLC I need to go sorry I forgot
forgot forgot about I forgot about the
funny walks I also forgot about
everything
um let me get familiar with what dick I
forgot about dick uhrin I forgot about
gumption grit Forge and Hornswoggle
Deadeye oh man I do love me some dhikr
and quick on the draw dirty poker shoot
nanny
oh shoot nanny I forgot about shooting
nanny I probably should have given to
shoot nanny anyway so to get this gone
we have to go all the way back to dirt
water and there's a long journey
apparently not that long okay pick the
lock alright woah meat holy [ __ ] that
was a lot of meat I forgot that the
currency was meat in this game but holy
[ __ ] that was a lot of meat do a good
start this is pretty good okay this is
it this is the ghost are you rubbing
your crotch on the ground I have no idea
what that was about anyway there's a
weird ghostly carriage here get in yeah
sure you hop in the ghostly carriage
which seems to support urine Garry's
wait well enough and invisible driver
yells yeah on cracks an invisible whip
and an invisible horse snorts and the
carriage starts moving and soon you're
out of sight of dirt water okay oh it's
in a ride in a ghost carriage god it's
been so long as its yes
: unmanned truck reckoning reckoning
that gun manner oh is that a ghost
forest okay a thick gray fog envelops
the carriage and you lose all sense of
time and space eventually the fog clears
in the carriage parks near a very large
and ornate mansion a disembodied voice
calls all aloud for gun Manor last stop
all right cool hi Gary how you doing
wow this is the biggest house I've ever
seen oh that's me it is very big miss
how many goblins could live in that
house is that a rhetorical question
do you guys even have those why like a
question that you asked without
intending to actually get an answer no
what never mind okay Gary insightful as
always thank you so much oh hi it's a
lady carrying some weird equipment
excuse me do you work here who me nah
nuts I can't find any employees in the
gift shop either I haven't even started
this job yet and that's already a pain
in my neck all right what's wrong oh I
love the music oh I love that music
that's so cool I can't get inside mrs.
Gunn hired me to come out here and deal
with a bunch of Spooks that are haunting
up the place I can't do that if I can't
even get in the front door though who's
mrs. Gunn you've never heard of Terry
Gunn should I have well I would think so
she's a pretty famous inventor you've
got a best-known invention hanging right
there on your belt she invented belt
buckles Wow
guns she invented guns oh okay all right
spooks like ghosts exactly like that yep
thirteen of them according to my
instruments
Florence Cunningham Cunningham goes to
Knights and services that's me
interesting what do you annihilate them
with science I was gonna guess that
weird kind of rifle looking contraption
you're carrying yeah it shoots science
what's wrong with front door the front
door well it's locked
no not locked no so what's the problem
okay see I'm a ghost hunter I ain't a
spider hunter I don't hunt spiders at
all and there's huge gross hairy fang
drooling giant spider in the for yay so
until I find another way in or find
someone else to take care of the spider
hunting side of this biz I'm staying
right the frig out here okay I can see
you feel pretty strongly about this I do
yeah well maybe I can help you out
hey that'd be swell
oh you know you look reasonably tough
and/or wily why don't we team up I'll
handle the ghost and you can handle it
things that aren't ghosts
okay all right Florence let's go Roger
copy it's mom flu actually okay oh you
tried the front door handle it doesn't
seem locked but some kind of force is
holding its shut yeah some ghost is
playing tricks on you because they know
you ain't back in science stand back I
got this Florence on limits are weird
rifle and fires a short burst of
swirling light into the doorknob you
hear it each sound from inside and the
door swings open
works every time sure it does oh god
what are you dancing Oh spider and Gary
just breathing I think how we doing
floors there it is kill it kill it kill
it okay dang just try being a tiny bit
cool about it will you okay thank you
doesn't seem that scary alright guess
I'll just well so bad
easy for you to say alright it's Oh Oh
Oh miss Gunn hi newfangled electronic
intercom system the intercom is making
annoying humming and crackling noise
press the talk button hello ah ghosts
just said hell at me spooky pretty sure
that's not a ghost it's just the
intercoms busted hello hello who is it
mrs. Gunn no I'm mrs. Gunn
oh man that would have been pretty good
joke if the intercom wasn't broken would
it miss Gunn did you know you're in a
commons broken you'll have to speak up
my intercom is broken we just gonna do
these vaudeville
what do you mean old it's 1895
vaudeville is at its peak miss Gunn
we're here about the ghost extermination
you requested well one of us is and the
others just generally adventuresome can
we have a word I can't quite make out
what you're saying come up to the third
floor
alright the busterred floor it's that
all right sure yeah yeah yeah the house
of mrs. Terry Gunn Theresa Terry Gunn
1847 built this stately if
architecturally unusual manor house in
the late 70s completed in 1877 using the
proceeds from her famous invention the
gun
after her retirement in 1891 she
graciously opened many of the rooms to
the public as a museum and historical
center that is in fact interesting okay
her it's as cold as a federal grand
administrator just hard in here
I wonder what's causing that you don't
think it's you know all that ice now you
got it backwards the ice wouldn't be
here if it wasn't cold to begin with
that's science maybe the house got heat
shut off somehow
we'd better see if there's a furnace or
boiler or something you'd probably be in
the basement all right let's have a look
around oh that is in fact a lot of ice
not sure what to do about that what is
this oh my god oh my god oh my god holy
[ __ ]
Oh Fortuna Oh oh my god fudge mental
you've eaten an entire beaker of fudge
and you feel great about it oh my god I
forgot about all this okay well I've
been angry that's right I forgot I was
angry I forgot about that okay let's
just go for it before something terrible
happens to me Oh nope not that all right
hello parlor rats it all right T Leyden
cart laden with tea Oh
I got tea tea service tea pot and some
cups in a pewter tray just add a bunch
of imaginary friends and you've got a
tea party great not sure what that is
but okay oh the blex caliber Oh for God
I got this out oh I forgot I got that
out of a spittoon in the spittoon hat oh
yeah I forgot so much oh my god I forgot
so much about this game oh no oh this
game is so good I love this so much
okay cellar the doors barred disbar it
you remove the bar from the door and
hurl it out tonight if by window all
right sure okay hey what's up yeah all
right what's crackin Florence oh holy
jeez look at all those spiders there's
some kind of surprising number of them
huh listen I'm just gonna stand over
here in hyperventilate a little you
wanna add and if you need anything feel
free to come back over here and tell me
about it okay
all right box of old photos they're all
photos of boring looking people you
don't recognize all right Wow looking a
bit cave but square it is being I know
you've seen a basement before Gary I met
you in one ha yes Gary is goofing still
very bigoted is being yeah you're not
wrong all right a plot Cole okay lucky
for us I have the key for every model
they make okay oh hey a lab check it out
Florence starts excitingly poking around
they might have been doing some really
good science stuff down here I don't
even recognize how these stuff
well don't accidentally blow us up or
anything I have an advanced degree in
tinkering and fiddling I got an advanced
degree and dhikr and you don't hear me
bragging about it
actually I do you assume of these three
boxes all contain the same thing but you
don't know what it is
so we're bench is littered with scrap
metal and a little canisters labeled
bismuth and do not eat chart with 76
elements through Liam chromium silver
left room for ones that happen but
discover like char on wool war iam and
soon on a workbench with a device on it
this device clearly has a purpose but
you can't fathom what it is maybe that
blueprint on the wall could help you oh
okay I can figure it out apparently hmm
aha
it's a device for reducing the loudness
of gunfire uh silent her if you will oh
you definitely can make a silent er here
the first thing you'll need is a one
point two three three seven diameter
cylinder maybe a tin can would work
you'll also need some stuffing to Pat
out the inside of a can that's gonna be
tricky to find okay right
it's a bands covered with gunsmithing
tools and supplies mess with them
you really don't know much about
gunsmithing so you just kind of randomly
cram pieces together until you have
something gun shape you got an item the
worst gun oh no I really got the worst
gun oh my god that is in fact the worst
gun oh my god
deal stench ooh I am I using this muck
covered blunderbuss this is no no
actually this is better well this one
gives me Moxie ooh that's pretty good I
don't know if that six Moxie is worth it
but I kind of like it and I like the
idea well they're both gross but I like
what I got going on here all right
cabinet full of aid supplies okay that's
good you box of science to Aquis I would
do in Florence she raised an eyebrow
even glances at one of her weird
instruments according to my weird
Riz they're 13 ghosts left on the
premises more precisely there are four
left on the first floor four in the
second and five on the third I found
something for you oh okay good glad we
could do that
Florence's gun damage the bill didn't
even know she could shoot okay thank you
very thank you for that you have
anything to say about this for so many
things are being here yeah it's all
tools and lamp equipment and stuff I
don't know what most of it is a human
not knowing human tools too many tools a
human having it's not every argue with
now I'm kidding I'm giving him more of a
Kevin from the office kind of a voice I
don't remember what I had before it's a
big can of paint with a brush sitting on
top of it paint something on the wall
[Music]
Wow uh what Horrors lurk inside this
thing it's bones well bones and pants
you got double silk pantaloons okay
great that's great are they better than
my spit ones they are that so much moxie
that's the most moxie I've ever seen Wow
that's a lot of moxie okay good I guess
great hey spiders let's fight Oh where's
my shooting Annie there it is shooting
Annie fan Amer shoot this target three
times doing 300 damage holy [ __ ] okay
let's do this one go for it
hey I got him oh one one damage one
damage Oh will you suck
alright whatever fermented spider blow
this is a glob of spider blood the
reason you carry it around is the
outermost layer of it as clotted
slightly forming a kind of rubbery skin
you can use to carry around the rest of
it
gross
oh hey okay good news is that there's
only one spider bad news is this huge
okay Dan inside this place is sad
whatever I said oh oh there's now two
I'm not sure what can I even do anymore
I've kind of forgotten what I have a
shootin Annie well okay I guess that's
the risk of shooting Annie I seem to
remember shooting Annie working a little
bit better before I do oh boy this ain't
good um alright you're just gonna go
shoot you oh I forgot about okay well my
gear Gary why are you so wimpy with
loser are you guys suck but at least at
least my gun still works maybe I should
just shoot him straight up because that
seems seems like the better option bang
okay I don't remember how to play very
good so don't expect me to be very good
spider egg omelet looks like a spiders
eggs got scrambled up and cooked somehow
well you were fighting it you're not
sure where the plate came from though
bless this mess ah good this pie safe is
really working overtime what with all
the spiders oh you you got whatever used
to be in this pie has been replaced with
teeming swarms of the offspring of the
spider who ate it that's so great for
that Oh more great Oh what's this you
say how's tricks flow according to my
weird is for insta oh no not about that
what about this no oh you got nothing to
say about this seems like you like this
machine it seems to you like this
machine is designed to suck up coal and
send it through the wall but then again
you're no experts in matters of coal or
sucking alright that was worth reading
twice ok ooh it's a huge amount of food
and various state
decay maybe someones trying to start a
compost heap that would be the
charitable explanation anyway I need
stench resistance don't I have something
that can give me stent resistance oh
I've got so much [ __ ] the flowers
okay let's try ah there we go okay I got
jumbo shrimp fork
Oh deals extra damage against cows and
other demonic creatures nine Moxie this
fork is too large to eat even the
largest possible shrimp with and it's
made of solid silver rich people make no
sense ain't that the truth
that is just purely better alright fork
fork it is smells like coal but it's
empty the remains of a coal delivery man
his bones are charred as though he were
burned in some kind of coal man stove
search alright done man or carriage
house key okay oh don't matter hedge
maze Oh Oh weird this bush seems to be
full of Pinto and kidney beans you
didn't think those grow on bushes and
you especially didn't think they grew on
the same bush you'd be right about oh
alright
these things are more aggressive than
most of the foliage you've encountered
except maybe that holly bush you fell
into when you were three okay Oh Oh mr.
County you say well I don't I don't need
that so how about you just eight damn it
alright how about you do miss Katella
biscuit ality then maybe a shooting
nanny a hedge shooting nanny okay does
that just not work for fun or something
what is the deal with that Oh Gary
please all right how about you try to do
this oh that wasn't so bad
alright for ya
[Music]
alright well that was easy magic infused
leaf this leaf still tingles with a
magical energy that animated it when it
was part of a Mullin malevolent topiary
beast alright with thanks you think a
gal could sit and eat her lunch in a
weird hedge maze without getting costed
by monsters what it's worth coming to
you said it is it safe to go I should
get back to work
what are you doing here I work in the
visitors center I run the token smashing
machine the we sold these little brush
tokens stand with the museum logo you
need to use them in the wishing well or
run them through a machine that rolls
them out flat and samsa museum logo onto
it that's my job it stamps the museum
logo onto them again yeah but they're
longer after that huh so do you think
it's safe to leave I should be fine
probably oh she leaves oh I just caught
that okay um Oh hedge wizards domain I
believe I believe that I'm oh oh oh no
oh no it's a maze who'd have thought
it's an action oh oh where am I now
wait the gun Manor hedge maze was
erected in 1888 for the entertainment
the guests and the families then two
daughters you are welcome to meander its
past so we recommend caution during the
winter below it as a handwritten note we
actually recommend staying out all
together because some crazy wizard moved
in and been animating the shrubs danger
oh that makes more sense that does in
fact make sense
I do believe that is actually of the
make sense thing okay so I went in a big
circle for nothing I don't know why I
did what I went in a big circle look at
me move I got a funny walk I got a funny
walk okay this is ridiculous
yeah you're not wrong oh [ __ ] oh my god
Gary no oh my god these guys suck
can I at least get some hits on a
shootin Annie please ooh strong medicine
oh that sounds good
but I don't have enough action points
apparently I want to shoot a nanny you
who's it gonna work out good at a good
feeling about this
yeah I got two for one well you don't do
oh you do okay you do a lot of damage so
I'm going to shoot you first
kaboom nice and then I'll shoot you
second these guys are tough like I was
breezing through the game last time I
played and I do now remember this being
that bad
glob a spider web big stupid blob a
spider web which you kept presumably in
case you run out of meat when it comes
to time by Halloween decorations right
miscellaneous spider parts a little pile
of miscellaneous spider eyes chitin legs
and organs you never know when you might
need to make something terrible I
suppose in a medium amount of time -
alright
oh jeez somebody's trapped in this
cocoon it's a mannequin oh that spider
must have been super disappointed why
was it moving I don't like the shadow on
you I don't like you it's that creepy
mannequin from before oh why was it
moving mmm very confusing no oh my god
oh my god we've get oh my god
this is anything but fair with my AP can
I get more AP there we go
smelling salts sniffing sniff that [ __ ]
oh yeah okay so I want this blog and
then I want to do this I'm definitely
gonna hit some now that is what I am
talking about now that that is what I'm
talking about
okay this hole contains approximately an
infinite number of spiders oh that's
great oh that's wonderful
oh this is the best oh I love this very
happy about this I'm just gonna go ahead
and straight up shoot these guys just
cuz I feel like that's probably the best
you're just gonna do whatever you do
Gary who's apparently nothing okay great
glad I did that boying and oh yeah you
can you literally reproduce that's
really gross yeah that's pretty gross
okay there was no point in doing that
but I did it anyway so I'm very
happy hello hey are you okay in there
what what I can't understand you hand
I'll poke your mouth hole there you were
saying hi hello salutations hey yeah you
okay
I've certainly been better what happened
I was practicing my greetings I'm a
museum greeter is that something that
requires a lot of practice practice
makes perfect right and there's an old
mannequin down here that's pretty good
for practicing on we've met anyway a
bunch of giant spiders grabbed me from
behind it was quite a surprise I would
imagine so I should probably get back to
work I wouldn't be right to allow
visitors to go on greeted can you let me
out of this cocoon maybe later
oh oh yeah go for it whoo thanks you can
get out through the coal chute down the
hall great stop by the entrance later
I'll give you the official museum
greeting all right thank you
ooh this looks fancy little spigot here
but since the boil isn't on it won't do
much of anything boiler is cold knee
indicated for the coal tank is pointing
to e all right so no coal there was a
cold there was a cold sucker here oh did
what is you oh hey whoa Nellie hold on
for a second that's a ghost those things
are dangerous I wasn't expecting to see
any of these here why you're a ghost
hunter and you're specifically here to
hunt ghosts no no no no that's just
ghost
this is ghost a greater haunt
originating from spectral transmissions
totally different from a ghost except
for the name anyway these those things
you'll be pretty tough heck I knew I
should have brought a bismuth bomb Oh
what bomb
bismuth it's a sort of silvery metal
that screws with spectral energy the way
iron does with magnetic energy okay so
where do we get a bismuth bomb bismuth a
boob Smith where do we get a pig Smith
bomb bismuth normally I've just made
before my cell block I do my lab well so
my bad idea well that worked Ben's we
found earlier might have some stuff we
need okay I remember there being bibs
mums I remember booms mum's okay anyway
was it here yeah
if Florence can you make a Bisquick bomb
out of this stuff bismuth come on man it
says right on the containers fine fine
can you make it though hell yes stand
back and watch a master at work
Florence goes down with the hammer and
pliers and comes back with a metal
here is a big grinning skull painting on
it and a big red button on the side well
that's pretty intimidating at least and
it ain't just a pretty face
okay bismuth bomb alright bismuth bomb
here we go
we should use this right yeah go for it
great better cover your ears and eyes
and bow just cover your entire head let
her let her rip let her let her rip get
it
Wow very very impressive okay so this
coal here it isn't just a trickle of
coal it's a huge pile a big old cart of
coal alright okay there's Cola under the
weird machine now so everything should
be ready to go with whatever the weird
machine does are you sucking I'm not an
expert in sucking apparently uh here we
go
blink hey that's good I think I hope if
it's not good then I'm in trouble but I
think that's good yeah probably anyway
thank you I guess we're done here
just gonna leave Oh aha turning on the
boiler solved our ice problem my
scientific hypothesis has been proven
correct but we don't have direct
evidence connecting the ice to the don't
you try and pull up Post hoc ergo
propter hoc on me I'll shoot you with my
science rifle in that case I totally
agree with you apparently let's hunt
some ghosts heck yeah alright it's one
of those round fruits this painting is
only kind of good whoa whoops rich folks
sure I've weird taste in art rats it
that's probably important like a coat or
something I don't know
your eyesight isn't good enough to
really examine this painting that's
funny cuz carrots are good for your eyes
area whatever there's a sign that says
only authorized and trained personnel
may operate this elevator try it anyway
are you sure you're not authorized and
you're also not trained I'll risk it
this is crazy
it's not a mine at villa Vader which is
simple and safe this is a fancy elevator
you have no idea what you're doing you
can't stop me okay it's your funeral I
guess with an elevator shaped coffin
properly I'm doing it you mess with the
levers and buttons for a while but you
can't get the elevator to do anything
see I told you this wouldn't work
yeah you're right a painting of an
elephant would love this that's
hilarious a still life of a fruit
technically some decorative diet dried
plants the life of a fruit wait still
life of a fruit a still life of a fruit
technically oh I get it
that's funny radiators are burbling
merrily and producing plenty of heat now
okay
Wow a big rack of expensive looking
plates horrifying
it says boo I thought it was just a whoa
all right hello hi okay
oh geez eating goes to the worst why are
there more dangerous to be your soul or
something yeah they're just gross those
chewing noises uh please let me shoot it
I don't disagree but let me check it out
first
hi this ghost is cramming his face with
invisible food maybe he's the ghost of
an emperor correct his manners hey buddy
hey whoo come on man at least use a
napkin or stick your pinkies out or
something oh sorry about that
lunch is so long gree what's going on
here this waiter doesn't go out of my
goat food so he's just giving me
imaginary food oh but I don't know know
the difference so combat about dragging
him into this mess so I've been
pretending to eat it
tell humor I'm starvin huh you need some
actual ghost food maybe I can help you
out with it oh god yes wait we're
definitely what I want is a bowl of
chili a bowl of chili without a gun in
it okay I'll boy that's what I'm craving
I guess it's probably because of how I
died how did you die
well Gina from Chile they had a gun in
it did you choke what no it went off and
shot me to death
why did it look all I know is I need to
eat a bowl of gunless chili in order to
satisfy my hunger and pass on into the
afterlife okay all right I'll see what I
can do some loud pretending going on
okay one of the museum staff is
frantically serving empty plates to the
ghost who was play lead pretending to
shovel the food in by the fistful he
seems too busy to talk to you right okay
it's a deserted dessert cart ah okay
it's not entirely deserted it's only a
deserted absurd just desserts
you got small blow torch this is a
little blow torch used for making such
fancy desserts as creme brulee torch
Alaska burn cake in ruins
sorry that really tickled me I don't
know I kitchen hi
says here labeled chili spices that
might be useful okay I got chili spices
great cool hi there's a ghost here
mumbling and muttering in the ambering
about eggs alright hang on a second you
tried to poach an egg by shooting it for
God dumb yes that's what I did and
course I did that's how you poached an
egg Papa didn't raise no fool but that
gum first looking or first slugging her
egg rolled it all the way the bullet
ricocheted off the bottom of the cook
Biden got me right between the papers
for dead boob I saw how you poached an
egg are you talking out of your head
like that course it is no it isn't that
government my Pappy and his Pappy been
poachers all alive now I know more about
poaching you ever will you okay but
that's not the same kind of poaching
poaching is poaching I'm going to prove
you so wrong as soon as I figure out how
right oh he dokey then oh I can't right
ah someone left the ice room door open
that explains the ice close it right go
inside the ice room okay oh hello hi
excuse me seem to be trapped in a block
of ice that was just what I wanted to
talk to you about actually get me out of
here somehow besides the whole frostbite
thing I'm supposed to be running the
elevator and there aren't any improper
stairs in this crazy place so that's
kind of important huh let me think
okay maybe this would help whoa what
blowtorch jeez be careful about that you
turn the knob and spark the flame which
turns out to be about as big as a
cigarette lighter oh okay fine then over
the next 45 minutes used up the entire
tank of butane but managed to melt
through the ice there the lady can break
free of the ice thanks I've got to get
back to the elevator come by and see me
and I'll let you ride for free there's a
charge to ride the elevator no like I
just said okay ah frozen goods
Maji Mech Tech brand deep freeze unit
undefiable matter bags of frozen food
okay great I'll come back for you oh
hello
hey thanks again for the help back there
in the freezer this is the elevator
unfortunately all we can do at this
point is go to the second floor why is
the second floor the button for
third floor is missing I'll bet anything
the old housekeeper took in and hid in
some hilarious place
she loved wordplay that's why they fired
her that and all the stealing important
things in hiding okay second floor
please thank you let's go from left to
right I guess Oh
abstract buddies I don't know what these
mean but you mean you know they mean it
twelve times right a book is a terrible
thing not to read Oh what does this
switch do Oh God hey guys stop doing
that it's a big dictionary on a pedestal
could come in handy if someone won't
tells you to look up something in your
funk and Wagnalls look something up what
do I want to funk [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't I
can't type F funk and Wagnalls you look
up funk and Wagnalls in the dictionary
to criticize both a soup and a salad
thumper dink a cat near an aluminum
weevil all right a dog someone who
carries liquid for surgery bag of dicks
a wheel besides a burning screwdriver
right okay I'm sure I need to look up
something specific what about like a boo
you look up boo weird there's an entry
for that word but no definition just a
picture of oh no picture a picture of
what of you hello hi
ghostly librarian is glaring at you
excuse me but sheesh
oh sorry I was just [ __ ] Jesus is good I
suppose it'll do now what's your
question I don't remember anymore oh
wait no not that's not true at all I
remember now can you help me with
library stuff could you be more specific
I'm looking for a book on a specific
topic I'm afraid our card catalog is out
being reorganized someone stored all the
cards by call number instead of by title
or author which made it quite useless
you'll have to search the stacks
manually how do we get started if you
can find a book on a similar topic to
what you're looking for its call number
will direct you to other books on that
topic
okay uh looking for the precise
definition of a word there's a
dictionary over there regrettably it's a
viewers ad to date so it does have a
technocracy secular humanism or brunch
yet but should be sufficient for your
purposes oh wait
watch to slow cook by immersion in water
to shoot an animal
longing to the king ah interesting
I got that neat Oh identical looking
books with only numbers on their spines
you have no idea to where to even start
oh boy oh hi hello see guy lying here
trapped underneath large book you okay
under there no talking okay see take a
closer look
turns out the book about geology it's
bound in stone and it Pierce that each
chapters devoted to a different type of
stone and it's printed on slabs of the
stone in question I'm very muscular
oh thanks I thought I'd never be able to
get out from under there at least now
you know all about that particular type
of granite described on that one page I
think it's wrapped like that in the
first place well I work at the info desk
and the villager centered so on my
breaks I like to research different
types of info so you know just in case
someone asks I guess you never know when
someone might ask you about rocks
exactly oh man I mean lady I gave back
thanks kid feel free to snap I'm a
curator if you have any questions okay
thank you
you have no idea where to even start
okay apparently I don't know where to
even start what I'm able to talk to the
dude downstairs but let's go through
here first see if there's something else
oh no no no any cover by sheep bow what
does that mean Wow bunch of tees
avant-garde these are the three kinds of
tattoo that have been invented so far
statistics about the gallery oh ah
interesting list of 45 states okay you
wonder what'll get annex next maybe
it'll be the guy de haut territory stats
that there's only three statues here you
appear closely until you find the one
you're pretty sure is just a guy covered
in flour hey buddy what you're doing
look I'm 95% sure real person not statue
what are you up to I'm a statue go away
okay now I'm 99% sure go away what's
your name Paul go away hi Paul
I'm mum Fleur what are you doing I'm
pretending to be a statue so the ghost
won't
get me go away you'll blow my cover okay
I'll see what I could do it I guess
elicit boring laws from before the cows
came home and everything got fun a
posterior Ori
corpus delicti objection huh what are
you objecting to your face overrule them
what's your problem anyway
bad legal stuff you'd never understand
requires gun law
I know gun law don't I know gun law how
do I get gun law oh yeah try me fine was
the maximum legal caliber for a civilian
handgun 800 800 I don't know try again
when you actually know something about
gun wall okay can I find a book about
gun law can I get a book about good
there there must be a book about gun law
maybe I don't know looking for some of
that delicious paste what oops
no okay mmm okay whatever we'll figure
it out later I'm sure that everything in
this man shouldn't connects to
everything else somehow restroom flush
take that irresponsible wealth okay
medicine cabinet old-timey ointment
that's probably good okay fancy vanity
it reminds you your own fancy vanity you
pry the biggest and most visible chunks
of wax out of your ears great Oh what is
this it's like your normal bath tub but
the faucet is really up hide in this
curtain around it take the curtain it's
curtains for you I got a shower curtain
right okay guest room oh [ __ ] Oh Oh God
hello hello dear welcome to my little
B&B would you care for a room no thanks
I won't be staying that long
hopefully wait a minute what's B & B
stand for boo in breakfast oh okay yeah
that's what I was expecting
what do you say your B&B this isn't your
house oh I know dear but nobody was
using these guest rooms and they will go
suffering around with nowhere to be and
I got feeling a bit homesick for the
little B&B I used to run when I was
alive so I thought mrs. gun probably
wouldn't mind what happened to your eye
oh it was such a foolish accident I had
a guest I was suspicious of a nervous
twitch liberal man I thought he might be
mixed up in something bad and one
evening as I was passing by his room I
gave into temptation and peeped in on
him through the keyhole did you see
anything well only for a moment he was
cleaning a small pistol and I suppose I
might have made a noise and he suddenly
jumped in the gun went off
and I hit you that's right straight
through the keyhole that's how I died in
fact oh jeez I'm sorry thank you dear
it's alright serves me right for spying
on a guest that's how I look at it that
what's keeping you here Gil no I think I
paid quite sufficiently for that
transgression what then well I didn't
want to go to heaven missing an eye it
wouldn't be as nice without depth
perception so you need a new eye yes do
you think you can help me I'll keep an
eye out I mean I'll see what I
all right bye then all right see you
started to open with the ghostly Clerk
swoops in oh hey now sorry dear but I
can't let you go wandering in there well
I am what's not what's in there a tenant
they paid for the room and they seem
rather quiet private sort so I won't
have you disturbing them okay thank you
oh it really seems like there'd be a
door here it really does doesn't it
doors locked doors barred on bar it
quickly offers no note it can't let you
do a customer he hasn't paid his bill so
I was forced to lock him in there until
he does I know that seems mean but one
has to take a firm hand in these things
how much does he owe you
holy [ __ ] how's he supposed to get the
meat to pay you if you won't let him out
it's a fair question but that's on him
I'm afraid all right I got some
dickering for this would you take 450
well I suppose it's better than nothing
I've gotten out of him and he seems
perfectly contented to stay locked in
there so all right okay this cost a lot
hello one of the museum employees is
sitting here reading a magazine as you
can see congratulate him on his newfound
freedom congratulations i freed you
you're free huh
free for what well from being locked in
this room without nothing to do except
read that magazine ah to freed me from
having an excellent excuse for not doing
my crappy job well you've freed me from
the burden of relaxing in here instead
of emptying trash cans and cleaning
toilets great look you're a real hero I
could just lock the door again no it's
too late
I'm free free as the wind blows free is
my job blows thank you welcome
he leaves take all right there's no
toilet but at least there's a say
there's a mirror you know something
stuck in your teeth good great full of
self-help books all right emotional
magic of affirming your true self
growing the cosmos in 10 easy steps
emotional power of acknowledging
yourself purpose of tidying up love oh
it's actually a useful book modern snake
oiler issue oh oh yes okay read it whoo
what do I get
let's see debilitating toxins where are
they now gives bad about us in a combat
skill that will reduce the target's
Moxie recipe for a new kind of snake oil
good medicine lets you recover HP and
calm that's a good one
I like that good good medicine oh yeah
oh yeah oh yes
wait you practice snake oil when you
open your eyes again it appears
somebody's stole in your magazine
scoundrel perfect all right oh yeah you
danced it up man hey somebody left their
wallet in the nightstand grab it oh
that's kind of nice that's nice okay
goodbye all right pick the lock wait for
the clerk to look the other way and
quietly pick the lock enter the room
okay
tables stationary but there's no
stationery on it funny mirror on this
vanity doesn't work nice landscape
painting on the wall examine it this
painting of the countryside is nice but
there's nothing very interesting about
it it's like the sort of thing you'd
find hanging over the bed in a mid-price
hotel or a bed-and-breakfast come to
think of it I guess it's a little weird
that it's hanging up over a stepladder
instead of the bed maybe the last
document was a really short art
aficionado take a closer look happy
little trees oh hey Gordon in a
signature this is original Darius klieg
you've never heard of it hmm you know
now that you're looking closely at it it
seems like the painting is sticking out
from the wall more than you would expect
take it off the wall well what do you
know there's another painting underneath
a painting of a safe this house might be
really old it's got jokes of this
vintage that's hilarious it's painting
of a safe on a wall it's fairly
realistic painting this wall safe it's
captain ceci n'est pas une coffer a fort
take it off the wall find it is of
course a wall safe of course
okay examine it you inspect the large
wall safe which is securely locked okay
the safe swings open it's empty apart
from a rolled-up poster of Rita Hayworth
great safe is still empty search it
anyway determined not to have gone
through all this nonsense for nothing
you carefully search the empty safe
eventually there's a click in the back
of the safe swings open revealing a
secret passage I guess that explains the
stepladder finally here's that silly
secret passage you found go through it
great sewing kit so it is good one I'm
glad you think so
the homophonic nature of so-and-so
certainly is ripe for puns it yes is
that so yes very good very funny listen
are you gonna leave this container or
what why so serious
well you're kind of driving the joke
into the ground now and it's getting
really tiresome not really tiresome only
so-so
just come on this is totally stop being
funny is that so yes yes it is are you
just messing with me
jusers not wanted what's in this
I do want it I want it so bad look
muffler you're starting to get on my
nerves now so what so what is that
there's an item in here that you need
for progression and at this point I'm
sorely tempted not to give it to you so
don't give it to me then Oh God just
take it just take it and get the hell
out of the script is an elevator button
Chicago International passenger and
freight elevator manufacturing
established 1857 they started
abbreviating things at the end there
because they were running out of room
right thank you so much just leave thank
you good stuff the armoire is bigger on
the inside than the outside go through
it oh wait no I wasn't done okay there's
candy on the ice in nine out of ten
business would be appalled
you got cat's eye candy and sugared pork
balls great it's bad but no door I guess
that's why I call it a bedroom and
outdoor room Hey okay is that science
junk awesome
hello there are you here to laugh at me
no no no no I wouldn't do that no of
course you would nobody ever laughs I've
never made a single person laugh in my
entire career that's a left turn I
wasn't expecting what was your career
I used to design gags and novelties but
I was terrible at my job I couldn't come
up with a single novel idea this
conversation seems oddly familiar see
even my very presence is unoriginal
you're just being too hard on yourself I
bet you invented all kinds of good stuff
my best invention was fake fake looks
just like fake vomit but surprised it's
real that was the one that got me fired
what other novelties did you invent you
must have had a good one
well I invented a can of mixed nuts that
has a spring in it so when you open it
the nut spray out everywhere that's kind
of funny nobody would ever open the can
because of how it said deadly venomous
snakes on the label all right I would
open it anything else
you know those flowers you were in your
Oh pail and it sprays water in someone's
face when they smell it you invented
that it's a classic no I tried to
combine it with the chewing gum made out
of hot peppers you invented a bhoot
honoré that Mace's people huh okay
anything else people seem to like the
little sea monkey thing so I thought
maybe I'd do that except funnier and I
thought eating powder is pretty funny
you made it qing powder out of brine
shrimp no are their aquatic you wouldn't
work I use spider eggs oh my
I tried to make an ultra realistic stink
bomb using pure methane gas turns out
pure methane is actually odorless this
way farts smell bad well so it's
extremely flammable you know
unfortunately fish little cellophane
things that curl up in your hand and
predict the future sure sure
I don't know what happened but why we're
100% accurate it was always terrible
news okay I tried to improve on the
classic rubber chicken let me guess not
rubber good kiss anything else once I
made some glass silly you see through
people's clothes Wow right down to their
skeletons huh okay well that's still
pretty cool except up before the bar
where they get cancer yeah who told you
all the ones I can remember we can tell
them you again if you want sure Duncan
never mind or hang on buddy
talk to him how do you die I was working
on a new invention an exploding cigar I
thought that would be pretty good you
like it a cigar and it's fine for a
second but suddenly it goes off without
a big bang you jump in surprise and
everybody laughs because you nearly had
a heart attack funny right sure laid a
snag in development boom what happened
well I figured I'd use gunpowder for the
explosive and you could buy already
packed into those little brass
cartridges so that seemed convenient you
mean bullets my first test run was a
real mess I can tell you that I can
imagine
Joan anyway now I'm a failure and I'm
dead maybe I can help you out what do
you mean well your initial idea was
pretty funny I guess it's just your
execution that was a problem my
execution was the problem huh you're a
laugh riot maybe you could help me after
all see if I can figure something out
for you okay oh all right okay whatever
all right so I've got a lot of missions
but not a lot of end results I do have a
button though go to a third floor ooh
that's a donkey you've always hated
these things well that's great it's
really supportive hmm kid's room I'm not
gonna like that am i okay let's go good
go for it whoa
god there's so many rooms
[Music]
it's a doll mind how adorable just look
at all the little miners of mine Kurtz
of mine shaft in bowls of minestrone oh
what's this
I got a tiny stick of dynamite did you
know that firecrackers are just tiny
sticks of dynamite and that this one is
just an even tinier one and that a
pumpkin is technically a berry no did
not know that okay there's a much nicer
vanity than that of the average frontier
team okay varies powders and creams and
pomades to make yourself slightly more
presentable Daniel Boone what's behind
it all right that wouldn't don't got me
okay someone who's been slacking on the
geometry homework
tisk tisk all right geometry tech wait
no I needed something geometry Rufus
would probably understand this but you
sure as hell don't okay full of
schoolgirls skirts and other clothes
that you would not fit even if you think
they might suit you take a look fun law
rules for parla gun law fun law gun law
fun look unlawful LOC unlawful knockin
law what is this the devil's music you
yanked a needle away there we go that's
better
Hey look more science oh yeah I need to
give lady the science junk hey I got an
you're not lady Florence Florence I got
your machine Florence there you are okay
I found you some science junk hey go
done damage science blast okay what's
this Oh - oh well whatever I'm sure it's
safe medicinal gas yeah yeah sounds safe
very safe oh hi this looks sad it's a
toy box
who knows what horrors it contains you
got a stuffed gun but less macabre
expecting this is not at all effective
as a gun but it's also not at all
effective as a bludgeon
someone blocks with letters play with
them this little girl is serving
imaginary tea to her guests the doll
while terrifying is largely indifferent
the museum employee on the other end is
playing along with a rictus grin on his
face
the little girl wears an annoyed and
disappointed frown yeah attack the girl
look that sounds good yeah hello there
my name is mom Fleur can I join your tea
party if you want I guess but it's a
terrible tea party Oh what's wrong why
aren't you having any fun well I have
his dumb made-up tea
on a property party like mama took me to
tell me more about that party we went to
a real Tea Room who's so pretty there
were Vaz is with flowers in him
everyone's dressed up in suits and
pretty dresses there were white china
teacups for the tea real tea not
imaginary well that sounds very nice it
was it was so nice everyone was so
polite and charming and elegant well
until the fight started anyway oh there
was a fight well two of the gentlemen
there got into an argument I don't know
what it was about but I guess one said
something to the other the other didn't
like and it was so insulting you threw
his tea right in the man's face and then
they took out guns and start shooting at
each other right there in the tea room
whoa they were still really elegant
though they had little silver and ivory
pistols and they kept their pinkies out
the whole time anyway I don't remember
the rest very well except one of them
miss the other and shot me by mistake
I'm sorry thanks but it's alright
haven't supposed to be really nice so I
guess I don't mind so much but I didn't
get to finish my tea party
so I want to have another one before I
go except I don't have any tea and
make-believe tea isn't fun anymore huh
see if I can find some actual tea for
you I mean I have a teapot oh hello
what's that hmm still not getting it can
you speak up sins of shaking it if you
were holding an actual teacup it would
probably have shattered by now he's at
you through clenched teeth
sorry I can't understand you bye okay
great
cool wow that music is creepy whole
place is creepy full of baby supplies
you don't understand like bottle diapers
and burping rings Oh weird compositions
paintings bad in everywhere teddy bear
has been comprehensively
enthusiastically disemboweled hey the
stuffing would be perfect for making a
silent er sorry teddy this is for the
greater good wad of stuffing okay this
stuff in would be perfect for making a
silent er or a taxidermy turkey right
this is where the creepy music is coming
from right great that's great
I'm gonna go downstairs I'm gonna make
that silent urgent because I want to I
don't know what its gonna do for my gun
but I'm a I'm a gun kind of guy I want
anse Islanders okay
uh-oh I need a tin can where am I gonna
get a tin can maybe in the kitchen I can
talk to the guy in the kitchen now so I
can go to the kitchen and I think I
think I've got the
I've got enough for that right you hey
you don't poach eggs by shooting him I
have proof what in tarnation poach a
method of preparing food especially eggs
by simmering them in boiling water where
are bein Dom he dissipates into the
ether still muttering to himself yeah I
win then I win stove you need a bowl of
chili to give that ghost in the dining
room and this stuff seems relevant ooh
what you need
unfortunately ever since your
conversation with me not sure you know
what chili is anymore maybe you should
do some research oh okay lard lard lard
nest very good very good very good quite
good shelf full of pots and pans um
before I do anything farther let me let
me just check off this stuff that I've
got I need I need to go back up to the
library because I've got the fun law
also I maybe need to look up the
definition of chili a savory soup made
of bean spices and a go huh ain't that
something okay weird all right okay um
can you help me with some library stuff
I found a book that you might want to
put back I'll thank you put it back on
the shelf if you would the number on the
spinal Li due to its proper location
okay so I have a book fun law ooh you
flip through the book unsurprisingly
it's mostly about bored children can
stay on their parents hair for just five
damn minutes there's a little tag on the
spine indicating it came from the
mansion library okay we're at okay
ooh you find the shelf where fun law
belongs and put it back the next book is
called gun law which might be even more
entertaining okay we'll definitely give
this a shot yeah all right ooh done law
you know enough about gun law to know
that they who have the guns make the law
that's funny
okay so I got that that's good what do I
have what did I get I just want to make
I've got a stuffed gun maybe I could use
that in the chili as stuff gun but now
I've got the gun law so I need to take
this to this ghost lady to get her to go
away cuz I know gun law in fact I think
you'll find I'm quite come first and in
the finer points of our justice system
particularly as it pertains to guns and
gun related activity horse
you're all trousers and no briefs oh
yeah we'll try me smart lady
huh fine obviously aren't gonna leave me
alone so just ask your questions ahem
I'm mum Fleur Humperdinck speaking for
the record state your name occupation
and cause of death
Felicity Wainwright defense attorney
lost a court-approved trial by combat
what trial by combat has been outlawed
for like 15 years you do understand that
ghosts don't visually aged as time
passes right all right so your client
called for trial by combat which went
you and the prosecutor had to face off
in a duel that's correct
can you lost are you acting dumb to try
and throw me off guard I would throw out
the question why are you stuck as ghosts
because although trial by combat was
already well out of Smashing by this
time it was still a valid legal recourse
I should have been prepared for the
possibility but I wasn't my lack of
training resulted in an innocent man
being executed for murder move how was
he executed hanging I assume obviously I
wasn't around to see it
so to release you I'd need to prove that
the loss wasn't your fault
the trial drool was completely fair and
aboveboard there's no chance of there
being foul play on the prosecutors part
my loss was my own then I have to prove
your client was actually guilty and
therefore your feelings of
responsibility are misplaced look you
think you don't think I do about the law
how about you tell me the first rule of
being a defense attorney
don't make fun of the judges beard don't
refer to his gavel as a weird little
don't actually call it mom refer to as
gavel is a weird handle you have to
trust and believe in your client if you
don't believe your client is innocent
you'll never convince anyone else he is
either so if you want to convince you he
was guilty
you'll have to an uphill fight fella
you're essentially playing prosecutor
here all right tell me about the case oh
my goodness
by defendant with Matthew guilty
Macready accused of the murder of Victor
victims burry at noon on June 18th 1878
in Reno I have some questions your
client was actually named guilty come on
names don't mean anything I once had a
client named I I killed a guy resolves
actual legal names sure but nicknames
are usually given out of some sort of
basis you've never met a really tall guy
named tiny or a fat guy named slim
arguably the nickname guilty would
reinforce my client's innocence
I stole a absurd I killed a guy was it
cause of death Tim's rare he was shot
through the heart with a 45 caliber
revolver and did Macready own such a gun
yes he was holding it at the time and
subsequent imagination showed that had
been recently fired are you messing with
me
any further questions yes I do have more
questions go ahead it was at noon
precisely yes that was confirmed by
witness also McCready owned a fancy
pocket watch that chimed on the outers
they were witnesses about a half a dozen
of them I'm pretty sure there's
something you aren't telling me I'm not
obligated to play my hand face up mr.
prosecutor okay then go on hang on a
second shot with a pistol in front of
witnesses at exactly noon was this a
duel so you can add two plus two after
all well done okay well I know about all
kinds of gun law so I should be fine
when it comes to duels the book I read
was pretty thorough oh why don't you
quote me a relevant passage then sure
the issues surrounding duel law are
complex and cannot be properly addressed
in brief and so I refer you to the next
volume in the series for a comprehensive
discussion on the topic well nuts guess
I'll come back later god damn it
what jeez all right fine then okay so
I'm all that time for this episode here
but there's a lot to unravel probably
another two episodes worth if they're
gonna be an hour long but we're back in
West of loathing and I could not be
happier so thank you everybody so much
for watching look forward to more
episodes of this coming up very soon and
as always oh and if you have wait wait
wait back it up you haven't seen my west
of loathing series I recommend going
seeing it it doesn't spoil anything
seeing this first so you can go back up
one link in the description it's really
funny the whole way through it is really
funny so check it out thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]